hi guys scifi recapped here before we
start warning spoilers ahead today i'm
going to explain a 2004 american science
fiction and romance movie called eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind the movie
begins with a lonely man named joel
barish who wakes up from his sleep and
lives his boring life as an office
worker turns out that day is valentine's
day where people are celebrating with
their lovers or at least buying a
beautiful flower for their loved ones
still that day the single joel somehow
decides not to go to work and
impulsively takes a train out to montauk
he wishes that he could meet someone new
but it seems impossible as he is
incapable of making eye contact with
strangers
at a bistro a blue-haired young woman
catches joel's eye and he starts drawing
her in his sketchbook secretly they take
the same train and coincidentally sit on
the same corridor the woman realizes
that she is being stalked and decides to
start a conversation with joel
she introduces herself as clementine and
discovers that they are going to the
same destination rockville center the
young woman tries so hard to keep the
conversation going but joel is just that
kind of boring man that does not know
how to reply to a conversation
long story short joel comes across
clementine who is walking home and he
offers her a ride home the young woman
invites him to have a drink together
which he agrees to
joel reveals that he is kind of closed
mouth because his life isn't that
interesting
however she loves him the way he is and
suddenly tells him that she is going to
marry him
she also asks him out on a date joel
feels that everything is going too fast
so he leaves and returns home before he
goes clementine gives her phone number
to him and urges him to call her as soon
as he reaches home
upon arrival joe immediately calls her
and he agrees to go for a date with her
the next day they spend their night
together on a frozen lake where joel
shows off his knowledge about astronomy
to his lover after that he drives
clementine home but she wants to come
over to joel's house while she goes to
take her stuff suddenly a stranger shows
up asking if there's something he can
help but then goes away
the scene jumps back to a moment when
joel is crying in despair a few moments
later he tosses a cassette tape out the
window as he drives turns out that joel
just broke up with clementine the scene
moves to several days ago when he tells
his friends that clementine looked at
him like she didn't even know who he was
and she already had a new boyfriend
called patrick robb hands him over a
letter from lacuna a company that
specialized in memory erasing revealing
that clementine has had joel erased from
her memory and that is the reason why
she didn't recognize him anymore he then
goes to lacuna to clarify things the
administration officer mary orders him
to fill out some form and it is revealed
that memory erasing procedure is quite
popular in the city the doctor in charge
dr mirzwiak reveals that clementine was
not happy and wanted to move on
heartbroken joel breaks into the
doctor's room the following day and
requests to undergo the same procedure
as his ex-girlfriend after that dr
mirzoyak asks him to collect everything
that has some association with
clementine as they will be used to
create a map of her in his brain and the
technicians will erase her entirely from
his life while he is sleeping
he gathers the stuff and comes back to
lacuna with the help of stan one of the
technicians they commence with brain
mapping procedure asking joel to recall
the memories when he sees a certain item
joel then returns home as he reaches the
mailbox his neighbor frank asks joel
whether he has arranged a valentine's
day plan with clementine with an unhappy
face he says that he has not planned
anything and immediately heads to his
room he then takes a pill turns off all
the lights and suddenly passes out
outside the house two lacuna technicians
called patrick and stan sneak in quietly
and install the memory erasing device to
the sleeping joel
the memory erasing procedure commences
and joel wakes up in his mind he finds
himself in dr meerswiak's room while
seeing himself and the others are doing
the brain mapping procedure then he
jumps to memories where his relationship
with the orange-haired clementine is
falling apart joel gets angry at her
because he gets home late and was
driving drunk but she claims that he is
freaked out because he thinks that
clementine was sleeping with another man
joel confirms it disappointed clementine
walks away from the house and the memory
slowly fades as the room turns black
he chases after her and yells at her
saying that he is erasing her and he is
happy with that decision while the
memory is falling apart in the present
time the two unprofessional technicians
start drinking and talking about their
girlfriend
stan tries to focus on the work but
patrick keeps distracting him he tells
stan that he falls in love with one of
the patients they took care of
previously
he also admits that he stole her panties
which makes stan disgusted saying it is
an unethical action
not long after mary arrives in joel's
room and immediately heads over to his
kitchen to find a whiskey as the
previous memory has been erased joel
jumps to another memory where he is
eating noodles with the same
orange-haired clementine even though the
event takes place in joel's mind he can
still hear the conversation of the
technicians in the present he tells her
about patrick stealing her underwear but
she doesn't believe him at some point
clementine wants to have a baby but joel
denies the request as they are not ready
mentally jumping to another memory of
the orange-haired clementine she is
disappointed because it seems like joel
doesn't trust her and does not tell a
single thing about him to her they have
an argument and blame each other
clementine gets angry and wants to end
the relationship
patrick receives a call from his upset
girlfriend and wants to visit her while
the procedure is in process however stan
allows him to go since it is a golden
opportunity for him to be with mary
the unprofessional lacuna's employees
stop monitoring joel and start dancing
on the patient's bed it is then revealed
that patrick's upset girlfriend is
actually clementine and he tries to
impress her by imitating joel he keeps
joel's stuff that is related to
clementine and re-reads it when he is
lost clementine invites him to go to the
frozen lake
joel finally jumps to a good memory of
red-haired clementine where they are
spending their quality time together in
the bed and on the frozen lake however
all of them are slowly erased at this
point he regrets his decision and wants
to call off the procedure but it is just
too late and it can't be undone
stan and mary are going crazy and don't
care about their patient anymore on the
other side patrick is having fun with
the blue haired clementine on the frozen
lake and tries to do what joel was doing
at that moment
however the woman suddenly wants to go
home on their way patrick says several
of joel's ultimate phrases to cheer her
up but it fails
since no one is responding to him he
tries to run away with red-haired
clementine hoping that he can stop the
memory erasing process he recalls
several good memories of her and brings
clementine there but they start
disappearing one by one
he realizes that he must find a way to
avoid the procedure before waking up or
he will completely forget her clementine
suggests he wakes himself up and it
works for a second but it's useless as
he couldn't move
after that he attempts to bring her
somewhere in the memory where she
doesn't belong which is his childhood
memories they go to joel's four years
old memory and it works for a moment
this halts the procedure which makes
stan panic
he then calls dr mirzuiak who eventually
comes over to joel's house he is quite
surprised when he sees mary in the room
the doctor analyzes the situation and
manages to bring joel back to the
predetermined mind map causing joel to
open his eyes for a moment he sedates
him and the process continues
while working mary keeps praising the
doctor and seems impressed with him
filled with jealousy stan walks out of
the building to get some fresh air as
soon as he goes mary approaches the
doctor and kisses him
she reveals that she has loved him for a
very long time however mr mirzwiak
already has a family and it is
impossible to maintain a relationship
with her
joel and the red-haired clementine get
back to the good memories this time to
the moment when they are watching a
movie together in a car but everything
starts disappearing he attempts to hide
her somewhere deeper in the humiliating
memories but as expected everything is
slowly fading
not long after the doctor's wife comes
to the building and spots her husband
kissing his secretary she is very
disappointed and drives away the doctor
reveals that they have history and mary
had taken the procedure to remove the
doctor from her memory
mary immediately goes to the office and
finds a tape cassette of her testimony
before getting her memory erased
joel then jumps to a good memory where
both of them are having fun in the
bookstore but the girl suddenly
disappears
all good memories of red-haired
clementine are now completely deleted
the scene jumps to a moment when joel
sees clementine for the first time
it is when he and his friends are going
on a vacation to a beach he is not
interested in kite flying and suddenly
is approached by a green-haired
clementine however he realizes that this
is just a memory and it will be gone
soon so they decide to just enjoy the
last moment of the memory they sneak
into the unoccupied bungalow where they
say their last goodbye and clementine
tells him to meet her at montauk as soon
as he wakes up
at this point the memory erasing
procedure is finished and all lacuna's
employees leave the room joel wakes up
from his sleep completely forgetting
clementine the disappointed mary resides
from the company while stan approaches
her and confesses his feelings to her
she decides to mail cassette tapes of
all lacunas patients back to them
including joel and clementine
after that we are brought to the very
first scene of the movie where joel
impulsively takes a train to montauk and
meets clementine again after she is
erased the scene then continues when the
blue-haired clementine returns to the
car after taking her stuff she then
opens the letter from mary and plays the
cassette tape
it is revealed that before deciding to
delete her memory clementine wanted to
break up with joel because he was a
boring person
she confessed to the doctor that she
didn't like herself when she was with
him they are confused when hearing the
recording since both of them have had
their memories erased clementine walks
out of the car and heads to the room
while crying in despair
on the other side joel also receives the
cassette tape and learns the truth
at the end of the movie clementine
approaches joel and both of them decide
to start over again
subscribe to watch more videos like this
turn on notifications and leave a like
to help the channel out thank you for
watching